data science and machine learning are
the two most buzzed words in the
industries these days
hi everyone welcome to this video by
simply loan
today we will learn about data science
versus machine learning
data science and machine learning are
used in conjunction but
if you are looking to build a career in
these domains it is important to know
the difference between them
with data getting generated at a massive
rate data science and machine learning
technologies have become increasingly
important in the industries
to draw value out of these data and
derive insights
both data science and machine learning
complement each other but understanding
how they work is important
let's first begin by defining what is
data science
data science is a field of study that
largely deals with the use of modern
tools and techniques to process
clean analyze and visualize large data
sets
the data collected by companies can be
in various formats
it could be structured semi-structured
or unstructured in nature
data science helps to get valuable
information from this data
data scientists are professionals who
convert raw data into meaningful
insights
find market patterns and help
organizations to take important
decisions
data science is extensively used in
companies such as amazon
netflix airbnb and ibm
let's understand what is machine
learning machine learning is a field of
artificial intelligence that allows
machines to learn from vast volumes of
past data
and make intelligent decisions on their
own using algorithms
it gives computers the ability to learn
without being explicitly programmed
machine learning helps to train models
that learn automatically and improve
with experience
companies such as google facebook apple
and philips use machine learning to
build ai systems
now let's look at the relationship
between these technologies
the picture that you see on your screen
tells you
that data science is a broad domain that
covers ai machine learning as well as
deep learning
machine learning is a subset of
artificial intelligence and it covers
another sub technology
called deep learning deep learning is a
part of machine learning that uses
artificial neural networks to train
models
it works based on the structure and
function of a human brain
now here you can see the google trends
for data science and machine learning in
the united states over the past five
years
the graph depicts that the search
volumes are really high
and both data science and machine
learning are very much in demand these
days
people are searching for these terms on
google on youtube and other platforms
and want to learn about them
next let us understand the different
data science steps
the first step in data science is to
understand the business objectives
define the goals and find a lucrative
solution the next step in the process is
to collect the right data that is
relevant to the problem at hand
the data can be in various forms and
from different sources
up next we have data wrangling this
process
helps to convert the raw data into
another useful format
that would be more appropriate for
analytics
the fourth step in the process is data
exploration
exploratory data analysis is used to
extract valuable information from the
data and find
unseen patterns data modeling is the
process of creating intelligent models
using sophisticated algorithms
the result of the model will help
companies to solve complex problems and
make decisions
and the final step is data visualization
where data scientists visualize the data
and forecast future trends
moving on to the machine learning steps
the first step in the process is to
import the data
the data that is used for analysis can
be a text file
an excel file a dot csv file or it could
be
present in a github repository as well
the next step is to filter and clean the
data the data that is used for creating
machine learning models is mostly messy
containing missing values and is not fit
for analysis
hence it is important to clean the data
before use
then it is important to select the right
machine learning algorithm based on the
problem that we want to solve
in the next machine learning step you
should train your model and then
test your model with new data points the
final step is to improve the efficiency
of the model and optimize its accuracy
let us talk about the main objective of
data science and machine learning
so data science is used to find unseen
patterns in the data and discover hidden
trends using data mining techniques
data wrangling exploratory data analysis
statistical analysis
as well as data visualization
while machine learning majorly focuses
on using machine learning algorithms to
build predictive models and forecast
future trends
it is used to classify the result of a
new data point
machine learning uses supervised
unsupervised and reinforcement learning
methods to solve problems
with that let's move on and learn about
the popular tools used for data science
and machine learning
some of the tools are common to both
data scientists and machine learning
engineers
use a combination of tools applications
principles and algorithms to make sense
of data
sas and python are widely used
programming language and data science
we also have the apache spark framework
matlab
data visualization software such as
tableau and databases such as
mongodb and mysql now talking about the
tools and software used for machine
learning
we have python r scikit-learn amazon lex
as well as microsoft azure ml studio
we also have libraries such as numpy
pandas scipy
tai divorce and others let's look at the
applications of data science
the self-driving vehicle is a common
example of data science
data science is also widely used in the
healthcare industry for
drug discovery analyzing patient records
and building medical instruments
facial detection systems and fraud
detection in the banking domains are
other examples where data science is
used
coming to the machine learning
applications we have house price
prediction using algorithms like
linear regression you can create an
email spam filtering system using
machine learning
next we have stock price prediction and
vehicle routing optimization systems to
name a few
now let us discuss the skills that a
data scientist and a machine learning
engineer should possess
so a data scientist should be good with
databases and sql
they should have knowledge of
mathematics and statistics
data scientists need to have hands-on
experience with programming languages
they need to know techniques related to
data mining data wrangling data
visualization as well as machine
learning
now talking about the skills for a
machine learning engineer this would be
good with programming languages such as
python and r
they must be well versed with
mathematics and statistics
they need to know various machine
learning algorithms such as linear
regression
logistic regression support vector
machines k nearest neighbors
k-means clustering etc natural language
processing
deep learning and data modeling are
other essential skills a machine
learning engineer should possess
now moving ahead to the final section of
this video in data science versus
machine learning
we have salaries so according to
glassdoor the average salary of a data
scientist in the united states
is hundred and thirteen thousand dollars
while in india
you can earn nearly nine lakhs seventy
four thousand rupees per annum
now a machine learning engineer can earn
around hundred and fourteen thousand
dollars per annum in the united states
and in india the average salary is seven
lakh seventy one thousand rupees per
annum
now that brings us to the end of this
video on data science versus machine
learning
i hope you found this informative and
helpful if you enjoyed this video then
please like and share it
and don't forget to subscribe to our
simply launch channel thank you for
watching and stay tuned for more from
simply loan
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here